merci beaucoup je vais vous partager ma
vision expérience sur la plus grande des
structures vivantes artificielle qui
accueille la plus haute densité des vies
humaines
c'est à dire les villes aujourd'hui au
21ème siècle la ville nous sommes
aujourd'hui nasa monde urbain nous
sommes des plus belles villes du monde
paris et d'un signe d'une grande
métropole les villes pour nous
aujourd'hui c'est quelque chose est tout
à fait naturel nous sommes des urbains
la majorité aujourd'hui des hommes et
des femmes vu dans le monde
mais ce qui est important que c'est
cette croissance phénoménale dans les
même pas 100 dernières années qui vient
de passer vous l'humanité est passé de 3
milliards à plus de 6000 heures
aujourd'hui et l'activité humaine et la
concentration urbaine en a donné lieu à
droite à cette ligne blanche qui est pas
top
puisque nous avons dépassé les 4 500
perd 2 400 ppm particules par million
donc dé co2 qui met en danger d'une
manière donc très dur
la survie même de l'humanité à
l'échéance de 50 prochaines années la
vie humaine la vie urbaine
l activité humaine sont étroitement
liées pour connaître quelle sera notre
futur
si nous ne parvenons pas à une vision
intelligente et humaines de nos villes
aujourd'hui au travers le monde
que vous soyez aujourd'hui en europe
avec une petite croissance sur les 50
dernières années les prochains 50
dernières années c'est-à-dire 650 700
millions d'habitants par rapport à la
croissance que nous avons aujourd'hui en
afrique et en asie ça nous amène un peu
d'humilité sur ce qu'est ce c'est clair
à présent que l'europe et nos villes
urbaines aujourd'hui dans le monde
sur ces cercles que nous voyons là il ya
plus des gens qui habitent aujourd'hui
des dents au niveau urbain qu'à
l'extérieur de ces cercles est là et ce
sur toute la planète
l'afrique est un continent d'espoir ou
jeu
lui ces profils avec donc des pays comme
le nigeria
ça sert à la quatrième puissance
démographique mondiale a même pas
l'échéance de 10 15 ans 450 millions
d'habitants avec des villes comme la
gosse tu aujourd'hui pour s'être déjà 20
millions d'habitants quand il ya même
pas 15 ans il s'était à peine à 4 5
millions d'habitants
donc nous sommes aujourd'hui un ca monde
qui change tout ce qu'il d'alkyle
bascule non seulement d'une vie urbaine
mais il va skull vers une vie urbaine
qui va vers l' axe sud est de la planète
là où nous avons été habitués pendant
donc aujourd'hui des musiciennes jusqu'à
maintenant à cette hégémonie de
culturelles urbaines sociopolitique des
lacs nord ouest où nous vivons
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui la vie urbaine n'a les
mégalopoles la métropole c'est quelque
chose de couronnes 10 % de la population
mondiale de la planète aujourd'hui
habite dans 35 villes qui font un moyen
de 30 millions d'habitants la moitié de
la france
c'est ça aujourd'hui la nouvelle zone
urbaine qui va continuer à progresser
parce que ray mais diablement
aujourd'hui en europe où 80% de la
population presque habitent dans les
villes mais des pays continent'' qu'on
landes qui est la première demie graphie
mondiale a la chance de quelques années
et déjà donc pas majoritaire urbaines et
des pays continent comme l'amérique
latine où je suis né où il ya trente ans
c'était 70% europol 30% urbain savez
bien aujourd'hui sur cette portion
urbaine 30% et rural c'est à dire qu'ils
ne sont aujourd'hui au 21ème siècle donc
des urbains sur l'ensemble de la planète
avec une croissance qui continue et plus
en plus forte
mais qu'est-ce qu'il ya aussi des
nouveaux dans cette configuration c'est
que notre monde au 21e siècle est devenu
au même taux unique 8 r du nord au sud
de l'est à l'ouest de la planète
le bic 8 et au 21e siècle c'est aussi
courants que la vie urbaine
nous sommes aujourd'hui face à
l'émergence de l'humanité d'un mix
intrigue culture urbaine citadine
métropolitaine et culture de ville et
une culture aux biscuits terre où chaque
personne possède au minimum en deux
trois quatre appareils ubiquitaire et
cette quantité va continuer à progresser
nous avons aujourd'hui autant de smart
quelque chose tu es des humains et dans
quelques années nous aurons donc sur une
proportion de peut-être 4,5 bien plus
supérieur et le mapping des échanges
ubiquitaire correspond parfaitement à la
vie et à la culture urbaine
c'est donc la naissance aujourd'hui
d'une nouvelle approche par rapport aux
villes pendant longtemps le ville était
constituée d infrastructures d sur bis
un latin des espaces publics les soca
lola gura chez les grecs chez les
romains donc on laisse passionne et les
règles du bien commun la res publica
c'est à dire la politique des choses
autour donc au des citoyens qui est le
coeur de la vie de la cité
pour rappel est donc au second grecque
au 21ème siècle nous venons couplée aux
citoyens que vous êtes 52 vous aux
humains ce que vous êtes sakandé vous
loue des cuites et qui est permanente
qui est intrinsèque et fait partie
aujourd'hui des lettres urbain civis
ubiquitous bombes des pères aujourd'hui
ensemble dans la construction d'un
nouveau monde sûrs dans les pib la
croissance que je qu'avant mesuré par
rapport aux états et continuo mesure je
répare et à elle devient aujourd'hui
extrêmement importante et niveau des
villes et parfois il est plus
intéressant d'être donc au maire d'une
ville que ministre d'un état
quand on voit que le centre de gravité
donc du produit interne brut des villes
est supérieur à celui des multiples état
et l attractivité sociale économique et
politique du monde urbain et parfois
plus importante dans les villes qui même
deviennent par rapport aux états qui les
hébergent extraterritoriale d'un ses
relations il ya plus vers l action entre
paris et san francisco 4 paris-bordeaux
unis sony main évidemment de la couleur
politique comme il y en a plus des
relations entre san francisco et tel
aviv cassé sa francisco et boston
voilà donc ces mondes durban depuis
aujourd'hui émergent des vannes où nous
ramène à un nouveau monde que vous
connaissez aujourd'hui presque tout ce
qui est celui de la transcendance des
objets par rapport aux services
on ne parle plus de posséder ma voiture
je parle de la mobilité comme usage
social
je ne parle plus d'aller à l'université
dans des briques et précise je peux
prendre de cours par internet je peux
accéder au bouc
nous avons aujourd'hui des cultures
urbaines au bik 8h dans lesquelles les
fonctions sociales viennent prendre le
dessus par rapport à la possession des
objets et qui sait croiser entre elles
quand je me déplace en mobilité je peux
utiliser aussi bien un véhicule partagé
en vélo comme je peux marcher à pied
tout simplement d'un signe notion de
découverte de la ville donc la grande
question qui angoisse les gens quand je
me déplace dans lé monde entier c'est ce
qui m'avait l'été smart voilà et donc
c'est devenu aujourd'hui la baguette
magique n'avait l'été smart et je viens
une ville de smart et donc que nous
avons dans les revues toutes les
semaines tous les mois les classements
les cui la ville la plus intelligente en
france en europe et nous vivons nous
guider par les cui d'aymavilles mais
être smart aujourd'hui ce n'est pas une
question de silicium ou d'algorithmes la
ville n'est pas un algorithme la ville
n'est pas un ensemble du silicium laver
les votes avant tout une identité
sociale territoriale économique
géographique politique qui est par
ailleurs un projet chargé d'une très
grande histoire
aucune ville ressemble à une autre
chaque ville est différente la ville est
une abstraction qui n'existait pas il
existe des villes dans lesquelles je
suis et la ville de mende ont une
identité
la vue est aussi sensible la ville vous
parle comme nous parlons à la ville en
fonction de la manière comme nous vivons
avec elle puisqu'elle la ville est aussi
un organisme vivant et lobé y aux
problématiques des systèmes complètes
vivent la nécessité nos bus man et les
hasards l'aléatoire qui le ca tour en
permanence donc la ville n'est pas notre
capacité à utiliser massivement de nos
téléphones
est-ce que csu étaient et smart mais
c'est pas uniquement donc au japon
j'étais ado que ya pas longtemps c'est
aussi chez nous combien des personnes
regardent avec leurs propres yeux la vie
qui défile convient des gens voient les
trains de leur vie passée parce qu'ils
sont collés donc à cet instrument aux
biscuits terre que les enlève la vraie
percée
de la nature de ce que nous sommes au
plus profond de nous-mêmes barre-thomas
city je pense qu'aujourd'hui nous
pouvons des stocks
on passe à autre chose a cédé temps
passé à croire que les questions qu'elle
est cuit de la ville est relié au
silicium aux objets connectés et aux
derniers algorithmes que j'ai conçu pour
enlever peut-être quelques bouchons il
faut que la vie reprenne la place
d'aliments sains permanence qui la joie
qu'elle désire que la sensibilité que
les cessations de coûter bien dans la
ville et il faut que nous nous rentrons
dans cette notion donc de fête et de
joie parce qu'on peut le faire pour que
la ville soit un organisme permanent
bouillonnant ya un mouvement
donc je dis anosy allons-y effectivement
sur cette smart cities humaine qui est
un peu ma marque de fabrique dans cette
scène mondiale
la ville s'est n'y est pas et ne le
supporteront de champignons la ville
donc on fait des enfants
ces deux personnes âgées
ces découpes c'est de l'amour c'est des
lieux publics c'est ce public
la ville ces brassages c'est mixité
cette diversité
ces mélanges chaque fois que le soldat
sain des virements urbain la chose la
plus importante qu'il existe c'est quand
les gens se rencontrent entre eux les
bons retours d'investissements dans les
villes c'est les retours des collisions
les retours des collections les retours
des rencontres le retour du brassage les
retours des lames excités comme des sept
gars me rends lourd d'une conférence
auquel nous avait invités
la chose la plus importante c'est dans
la ville dire bonjour à quelqu'un parce
que le dire bonjour ça veut dire tu
existes c'est pour ça que donc aux jets
plaide pour que nous prenions conscience
de la complexité de la ville du désordre
métabolique qui s'opèrent aujourd'hui à
nos villes de l'obésité qui a gagné nos
villes dans sa croissance complètement
disproportionnée et également dans la
distanciation qui s'est créée entre les
citoyens et sa ville dans lesquels de
concept appropriation de l'espace public
disparaît
et souvent parce que le centre d'intérêt
au travers de lévis cuite et donc collé
des cales des ce qui devrait être son
centre d'intérêt c'est à dire tisser des
relations entre les uns et les autres
pour vivre des manières épanouie et
vivre ensemble
on n'a pas attendu le 21ème siècle pour
que la ville soit intelligente puisque
nous avons toujours ici d héritage gas
le roman pas loin des agoras et autres
une semaine ont montré que l'homme et la
technologie savent coexistaient ensemble
tu es la technologie donc aujourd'hui
est un outil indispensable si nous
sommes capables de comprendre le vrai
challenge durban et les chalands durban
que nous avons aujourd'hui va nous
quelle que soit la ville dans lesquelles
nous soyons au monde au nord au sud de
l'est à l'ouest c'est ne vient vivre
ensemble social l'identité culturelle
par rapport à l'endroit où je suis et
les miens créer de la valeur ajoutée
être capable a eu une économie dont
copie nous apportent ils certaine
croissance pour le bien être de tous est
conscient de la fragilité des ressources
écologiques et être capable de vivre
citations des crises parce que la ville
est permanent permanence soumise est
secoué par des aléas à tout instant que
personne ne peut prévoir c'est les
propres donc que des aléas c'est pour ça
que la ville intelligente humaine elle
doit être avant tout braqués sur la
qualité des vies sur la place des lits
manquent
quelle qu'elle soit la ville québécoise
à la ville c'est pour ça qu'ils devront
construire donc haut débit vivante
c'est pour ça que nous devons construire
des villes dans lesquelles nous sommes
dans ces notions de vie et des partages
c'est pour ça que nous sommes
aujourd'hui avec la technologie comme à
nantes avec les machines l'éléphant qui
constituent des lieux de vie et des
relations des hommes et des femmes
c'est pour ça que ce peuvent permettre
d'aménager n'est que des scènes les
quais de loire dé rendre la place aux
musiciens aux artistes aux jeunes aux
moins jeunes parce que chacun apporte
avec son nom propre intelligence
émotionnelle un regard sur la vie qui
devient les siens et s'approprie d'un
morceau de ville parce que la vie la
réalité est un patchwork la ville et
n'est pas homogène la ville et les
diverses non seulement par ses quartiers
mais les diverses par les origines
culturelles
sociale parce qu'une jour d'une ville
sont cosmopolites parce qu'aujourd'hui
nos villes ce sont des villes monde
comme l'a dit ça ce cas sa scène elle
avait le monde est une ville qui est
avant tout ouverte vers l'extérieur tout
en ayant sa propre identité
la problématique identitaire ce n'est
pas de dire je suis parisien et fier de
l'être
la problématique c'est à dire j'aime
paris mais je suis ouvert au bond et ma
ville s'est construit avec les autres et
cette intelligence émotionnelle
aujourd'hui jouent un rôle majeur
nous devrions être tous charlie et pas
uniquement le moment où une catastrophe
une crise s'est produit nous devons
aujourd'hui donc outre à sonder les
concept même de l'intelligence de la
ville pour aller à l'heure sur la sur le
concept qui partagent une ville
intelligente et humaine est une ville
dans lesquelles les partages s'installe
dans le coeur des hommes et dans
lesquels s'installent comme mode de vie
au quotidien
l'intelligence humaine de la ville doit
comprendre que nous vivons
collectivement qu'elle semblait ensemble
les urbains et que nous sommes
interdépendants les uns des autres et
que en même temps les tissus urbain
social économique culturel pour
l'éthique dans la ville est extrêmement
fragile
tout peut basculer d'un train à l'autre
une tempête des inondations mais aussi
des la vulnérabilité sociale et
économique qui peut se produire
nous le voyons un peu partout dans le
monde toutes les villes sont menace est
aujourd'hui lé monde par les mêmes fléau
souvent liées à l'activité humaine les
climats la pollution 80% des villes
aujourd'hui au monde offre donc une
qualité de l'air est respirable 10 l oms
il ya pas longtemps
les stress hydrique le mont cotton faut
aller chercher plus en plus loin la
montée des mers
l'afflux des réfugiés qui aujourd'hui
crée de nouvelles tensions sociales
urbaines les continue des services de la
ville
quant aux situations difficiles donc on
se présente devant nous les nouvelles
maladies urbaine la tropicalisation des
vecteurs des maladies qui autrefois
étaient les problèmes du sud
aujourd'hui c'est les problèmes dinero
si les premiers cas tsikas a été
déclarée en france
avant-hier des choses qui paraissaient
impossibles
la vulnérabilité et nos vies les plus
importantes qu'on le croyait
parce que nous sont face aujourd'hui à
des séries talent d'un urbaniste bonne
notre temps nous avons conçu le vice
dans les années 50 50 dans une version
pétrolière dans ses versions d'énergies
fossiles dédié à la voiture
nous ne citerons pas des hommes et des
piétons dans les villes qu'ils
s'approprient l'espace urbain et public
nous étions des hommes centaure mi homme
mi voiture qui circulait allègrement des
grands boulevards avait quatre cinq six
voix qui traversait la ville les temps
deux hommes sont horaires vont lui mais
l'héritage urbanistique et restez donc
nous avons aujourd'hui des villes à
sécher qui ont perdu leur biodiversité
l'eau n'existait plus donc quand les
arbres donc ont foutu le camp parce
qu'on va en habitués et donc pour cette
image a été prise le 4 juillet de
l'année dernière aubervilliers
ce n'est pas une partie peut cliquer
légende et plusieurs générations que se
réunissent autour bill fraîcheur donc
pour jouer des manières
intergénérationnel non c'est la crise de
l'urbanisme donc des années 70 avec les
hlm et la vulnérabilité socioculturel
que nacré dans les villes que l'on a pu
voir donc qu est ce qu on appelle les
banlieues et donc que les gens ils
viennent traquer la ville ils raclent
donc que le robinet des bornes incendie
pour pouvoir donc on disposait d'un
moment de fraîcheur quand il fait 40
degrés donc dans la ville de challans
incrémenté par les canyons urbains
pardon la hlm etc et aujourd'hui on
s'est posé la question à chaque été
qu'est ce qu'on va faire dans ces lieux
là parce que ceci va continuer dé plus
en plus chaque année ça sert à présent
plus parce que nous allons aussi vers un
réchauffement climatique de plus en plus
important l'état social aujourd'hui ils
font partie de la vie quotidienne et ne
sont bien placés aujourd'hui en france
pour les dire et ça fait partie de la
vie urbaine
c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui il est plus
que jamais indispensable de faire
renaître de faire naître s'il le faut
une culture urbaine dans lequel on
puisse s'approprier des concepts donc
que des bases qui sont la démocratie
mais non pas uniquement la démocratie
élective
hélène cratie participative l'équité et
non pas l'égalité l'équité et
l'éducation comme socle des changements
et des transformations des mondes
urbains
nous vivons dans une période de crise
économique et je dis que malgré tous ces
éléments là il ya de la lumière
au bout de tunnel urbain et que nous
pouvons avec l'inertie intelligente et
humaines redonné du coeur à la vie et
redonner de la vie à la ville un
permanence pour améliorer venir ensemble
à condition que nous soyons capables de
faire converger trois éléments majeurs
de transformation des 10,0 psion
l'inclusion sociale
la réinvention des infrastructures
urbaines et la technologie bi critères
comme et l'évier et les noms de
changement si nos vies ne sont pas
incluses ivre quelle qu'elle soit la
technologie qui n'utilisera on serra
toujours dans des tissus urbains qui
vont s'est désagrégée si nos villes se
réinvente au pas dans les
infrastructures urbaines
même si on a une démarche donc cohésion
sociale on essaiera capable de la rendre
viable et les infrastructures parfois
ses 20 ans ou 30 ans pour changer donc
plus que jamais aujourd'hui il est
indispensable de prendre des mesures
pour redonner la vie la vie pour
désacraliser la ville par rapport donc
aux grands projets urbains des voiries
des voitures et de grandes donc au
projet tient lève la ville de la vie et
pour redonner la ville aux habitants
avec donc comme la capacité
technologique et s'offre aujourd'hui
c'est pour ça que j'ai dit que les
challenges qui se présente aujourd'hui
les mondes urbains c'est l'hybridation
social technologique et la ville qui
vont dans ce sens là réussissent à
construire des l'inclusion sociale parce
que les capable de gérer ses soutes le
la nous vivons une période formidable
21e siècle nous parlons souvent de la
révolution biscuits terre la religion
digital mais c'était un aspect des trois
révolutions que chacun de vous est en
train de vivre aujourd'hui nous avons
une révolution des nanotechnologies qui
va changer la manière des serres
actionner avec les capteurs les objets
les matériaux la biotechnologie laden la
perception du corps humain et la
robotique cognitives et les assistants
personnels
c'est aujourd'hui la transformation
disruptive de l'humanité à l'aune de la
convergence des c4 technologie est mise
en valeur
mis en projection positionné pour
qu'elles traversent nos vies
pas comme le monsieur qui dort pas comme
les messieurs qui va se faire écraser
pas comme c'est lui qui simplement cg
localise donc pour exister un temps
qu'ils ont begeek puisqu'on peut être
hyper connectés y compris avec des
objets est totalement déconnectée du
monde social nous né pouvons plus aller
dans une humanité qui soit hyper
connectés et socialement déconnecter la
connexion aujourd'hui ses yeux dans les
villes dans nos quartiers par est ce que
j'appelle les pères proximité les 21ème
siècle c'est les sites de villes les
vingtièmes cet incident est et à l'est
d'une 9e et et les siècles des empires
l'hyper proximité
c'est la nouvelle bataille qui se joue
c'est à dire être capable d'être
connecté dans nos quartiers
dans chacun de nos lieux de vie tout en
les mettant au service du challonge que
j'ai évoquée au début de ces talk
sociales culturelles économiques
écologiques et des résilience la
technologie aac et nos vies depuis dix
ans puisque nous sommes souvent et
remarques des indépendants aujourd'hui
c'est la ville qui doit à clé la
technologie et la technologie doit acter
la politique pour à ce moment-là
réenchanter nos vies je les dis à mes
proches des élections en france on ne
peut pas réinventer un pays si on n'est
pas capable d un range chanter nos vies
c'est pour ça messieurs dames
chers amis rentrant chez vous dites vous
chaque jour comment je peux participer à
cet ouvrage collectif et collaboratif
qui est de réinventer nos vies donnons
le la place à l'amour
donnons la place à la fraternité
donnons le place à la collaboration
cette photo a été prise par un
photographe devant le bataclan sur
lequel aujourd'hui
donc quand on l'honore parce que nous
voulons que d'asseoir l'amour qui prime
dans nos villes et pas la haine pas le
refus l'autre donc vive l'amour
vive la ville vue l'intelligence
urbaines sociales et collaboratives
merci